NHS trust has been fined eight hundred
thousand pounds for failings which led
to the death of winter Andrews just 23
minutes after she was born Nottingham
University Hospital NHS trust failed to
provide safe maternity care after winter
was born by C-section at Queen's Medical
Center in Nottingham in September
2019. well Skies Becky Johnson is at
Nottingham magistrates Court hello there
to you Becky uh prosecutions against NHS
trusts are are not common are they
they're not common this is only the
second time that a trust has faced a
criminal prosecution for failings in
maternity care and this is the highest
fine that he has been handed down by a
court 800 000 pounds the fine for
Nottingham University Hospitals trust
the judge uh damning in her remarks
describing the systematic failures that
led to the death of baby winter Andrews
in September 2019 just 23 minutes after
she was born by emergency Caesarean
section uh the the trust pleaded guilty
on Wednesday to two counts of failing to
provide Safe Care One in relation to
Baby winter and one in relation to the
care of her mother Sarah Andrews and the
court heard again today how baby winter
died following that Caesarean section
which was performed too late it was too
long before care was handed over from
midwives to Obstetricians and winter
died because of a lack of oxygen to her
brain a death that was preventable a
death that was caused the judge said by
a failure by the trust to provide
adequate training for staff and indeed
by understaffing on the ward at the time
of baby Winter's death now the family
were in court to hear this sentence be
this fine being handed out and the judge
said that the fine would have been
considerably higher had this been a
private company but she said she had to
have in mind that this was an NHS trust
that was running in deficit that had to
continue providing care to patients at a
time of unprecedented pressures and that
is why she set the fine at the level
that she did but she did reiterate that
the culpability of the Trust In this
case was high and she said as I say that
had this been a private company the fine
would have been considerably higher than
the 800 000 pounds that she has fined
the trust today and as I say the parents
of winter were in court we are expecting
to hear some reaction from them very
shortly to this fine being handed down
we know that when the trust pleaded
guilty Sarah Andrews said that she had
been failed in the most cruel Way by
this trust Nottingham University Trust
of course the latest to be under
investigation for a catalog of maternity
failings last month's Donna ockendon the
independent Midwife investigating the
trust updated that at least 750 families
had so far contacted her about potential
failings in Care by this trust and we
are expecting to get reaction from the
trusts chief executive to this a little
later today